all right Diora
you're a wage girl where are you from
originally
well my okay my dad's part of the side
of the family he's from St Louis mom's
side of the family they're from
California
29 pumps
and how was your childhood
um
I didn't find out who my birth dad was
until I was 17. oh really and in a
maternity home
and uh my time was with my mom because
that's what I grew up with it was rough
I was in and out of foster care all
types of stuff why were you in foster
homes huh why were you in foster homes
um my mom couldn't take care of us so
she got all of us taken over
two times oh is that right what was your
mom into that she
um
entrepreneur oh
just like you yes you the Apple didn't
fall too far from the tree
and uh what kind of doing better I'm
sorry I just do it better you do it
better
good for you
you uh how far did you go in school
um I graduated I didn't go to college I
want to but after
the after
I'm done doing what I'm making money I
have goals
what kind of kid were you in high school
huh what kind of kid were you in high
school
um
I don't know
I was like
crazy
so you had a it sounds like you had a
baby yeah early on what how old were you
I'm 20. but how old were you when you
had to stop when I had my daughter I was
17 17.
and you're raising her yep
by myself by yourself
and this work you're doing now that
started what age
um at first I wasn't really doing this I
was like doing a more dangerous way
and
like
like I don't know I'm not into the whole
12 an hour thing I can I don't want to
do that you can't do a square job I
don't want a square job
that life is not meant for me
so
so where the sex work started for you at
what age
it's not even sex
I don't sell sex I sell time
so
I mean you're selling your time I mean
how long you've been selling your time
like
a year and a half now
and you're you're independent or you
work with it I'm independent dude
and you're working Figaro Street
sometimes you do the internet as well
yes
what's what's the difference between
working the internet and working your
streets the streets is more dangerous
we had bad things happen then huh have
you had bad things happen when you're I
mean yeah like come on now if you're out
there everybody goes through stuff
everybody out there like
everybody has had at least one
experience or
sustain one experience or something like
but yeah it's dangerous this lifestyle
is not meant for everybody that's for
sure
this is dangerous and you do have to be
careful
you've learned some things to keep you
safe huh you I assume you've learned
some things that help keep you safe
yeah what what kind of stuff do you
learn hey no free game
oh I see you don't want to give away
your secrets
it's understood you get it are drugs a
part of your life
um what did you say are drugs a part of
your life what do you mean drugs like
crystal meth or crack or anything like
that I don't know
I've never tried it and I don't want to
yeah
to do this I smoke weed but that's about
it does the does weed or alcohol or
anything like that help you do this kind
of work do this work no
you'll be sober doing it yeah
why would you go out there drinks
or
okay
tell me about your customers
are most of them married you think
clients your clients
Maybe
you don't ask no
some of them that become regulars we
talk and everything but like I don't
know like most of the time when I see my
clients I don't actually do anything
because I don't actually have to I don't
have to talk to someone
like literally
yeah I've heard that from some of the
girls
and then not only that like
like most of these people out here they
don't ask for sex and stuff they just
want people to talk to like someone to
be talking to and they will say that
it's about the companionship of a pretty
girl
you have friends
friends yeah no friends more bands
you
didn't love before no no
I'm in love with my child
yeah that's about it that's great it's
great that you're raising your daughter
a lot of people
fold can't say that yeah
I know
do you have any regrets in your life
um foreign
not regrets but it's a few things I
kind of wanted to change if there was
like time travel but
not regrets
are you saving money
yep you are
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw when you were young
[Music]
not your parents it sounds like
well I was more closer to my cousins
than I was to anybody my cousins and my
sister
other than that I was not um
I'm good you never saw anything
that would give you an example of I want
a relationship like that
a no
how does this work affect you
emotionally
it doesn't it doesn't does it build up
your self-esteem or knock it down or
I mean
I don't know
I don't know because I don't think about
it you don't even let it bother you
some people are like that
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking about doing this
kind of work
what do you mean as a young girl like if
if a girl of your age or younger
who's considering doing something like
this well someone younger than my age
I would tell them not to well I wouldn't
tell them not to do it because well I'm
not going to tell you to do it neither
so like I don't know I wouldn't really I
wouldn't suggest them to do it because
coming down there are girls who go out
here and stuff happen to them and they
get killed or
kidnapped or trafficked or anything like
you never know so this life is not meant
for everybody
how do you think it's changed you
I mean it's opened my eyes
to a lot to be honest
have you learned things about men that
you didn't yeah what have you learned
about men
I can't tell you that
you're no fun
huh you're no fun
you say I know
do you realize that
this is a crazy dangerous way of making
a living
do you ever stand back and look at it
and go man this is nuts that we're doing
this I know it's dangerous I know it's
dangerous yeah
but I mean
hey
I like it you enjoy it
I like what I do
I wouldn't say that I like like
literally like I'm not a porn star I'm
not no
not into our lab but yeah you like the
game of making I like yeah
it's like Monopoly yeah it's a way to
make fast money
are you addicted to that you think
you'll be able to pull yourself away one
day
yeah I plan on stopping doing this when
I turn 26 yeah I won't be no longer
doing this what would you like to do
um study law become a divorce lawyer oh
that'd be great
yeah it's good to have goals like that
have long-term goals and short-term
goals
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
[Music]
um
the most important thing I've learned
uh
keep my eyes open pay attention
to everything that's going on around me
because you never know
all right Dior thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem appreciate
the best of luck stay safe out there
thank you you too thank you